hi i'm george celevski and i'm a
research scientist at ibm tj watson
research center
today i've been challenged to teach one
concept and five levels of increasing
complexity
and my topic is nanotechnology
nanotechnology is a study of objects in
the nanoscale
between one and a hundred nanometers in
size and it turns out that
objects in this size scale have really
interesting properties that differ from
objects at a macroscopic
scale our task as nanotechnologists is
to understand these materials
understand their properties and then try
to build new technologies based on these
properties
at the end of the day my hope is that
you'll understand nanotechnology at some
level
[Music]
hi are you bella yes bella i'm george
nice to meet you
nice to meet you i'm a research
scientist do you like science
yeah i wanted to talk to you about a
specific type of science called
nanotechnology have you ever heard of
this word before
nano's kind of a funny word right it's a
word that's used before another word
and it means one billion what's the
smallest object you can think of
a baby ant a baby and very good
so i have over here a meter stick let me
show it to you and so that's a meter
and if i divide it by 1000 i get a
millimeter so milly just means one
thousandth
there's all these little lines on the
ruler and each of those little lines is
one millimeter
so baby and is probably a couple of
millimeters so even the thing that's the
smallest thing you can think of it's a
million times bigger
than a nanometer tiny tiny tiny tiny
tiny tiny
if i took this stick and i was to draw
one billion lines the distance between
those two lines would be one nanometer
so that's really all it is it's just a
measure of size but it's really
really really tiny you know smaller than
anything that we can see
with our with our eyes the reason why in
nanotechnology we
you know in scientists we care about
things that are that small
is because there are objects called
atoms have you ever heard of atoms
before
yes um i first heard of them on a show i
watched
called storybots they're just little
things that make up like
everything on earth even earth
that is a perfect explanation but what
if i told you that
scientists invented a special type of
microscope
that not only lets you see atoms but
also lets you move them around and build
things with them would you think that
would be pretty cool
yeah so it's called a scanning tunneling
microscope
and not only can you see the atoms but
you can move them around atoms are kind
of sticky
you can actually build things using this
instrument with
actual individual atoms so if i gave you
that machine would you want to make
something would you want to look at
something very carefully
i would want to make a unicorn have the
atoms
you are definitely a second grader my
daughter would probably answer the exact
same way
a unicorn would be awesome why do you
study stuff so
small i study it because objects that
are that small
have really interesting properties they
behave
completely different than objects that
are big
and because of that we can build really
cool things with them
like really fast computers for example
or new types of batteries
or new types of solar cells and a lot of
nanotechnology is kind of like playing
with legos you take these small objects
and you you put them together to build
something new something interesting that
no one's built before
it's like legos for scientists cool
so how old are you i'm 16. 16. so what
is that you're in 10th grade
junior year so 11th grade so have you
heard of nanotechnology have you heard
of this term before
yeah i've heard of it what do you think
of when you think of nanotechnology
it kind of seems very science fiction
you know you're right when you read
about some of these technology it does
feel like science fiction but the part
of nanotechnology i wanted to talk to
you about is
stuff that you probably use every day
most of your day all of the time can you
guess what
aspect of our technology i want to talk
to you about my phone
yeah so modern computer chips rely
heavily on nanotechnology does this look
familiar to you can you guess what this
might be
i don't know so this is a silicon wafer
and they're embedded in basically almost
every object that you use from a laptop
to a phone to
cars television sets appliances
we end up cutting these into little
squares and those repeating patterns
each
of those is a processor and those chips
are what goes into all of these objects
what i want to talk to you about is how
we got from
kind of where we started and how we're
able to actually
fit 18 billion of these little devices
in a little you know one inch by one
inch uh
area they're called transistors it's a
switch very simply think of it as a
light switch that turns on and turns off
using an electric field by applying a
voltage
i went through my kids lego bins to
build a very simple model
of a transistor and these are wired
together in circuits
so that you can do computation you can
do logic with them where nanotechnology
comes into play
the way you double the number of
transistors on a chip can you guess what
you would have to do to this transistor
you make it smaller
you have to make it smaller exactly but
here's the problem so about
oh 10 to 15 years ago the devices got so
small
that if you shrunk them this gate that
actually turns it on and off
loses its ability to control the channel
and so they did was they took
devices like this into these things we
call them finfets
kind of like a fin on a fish so they're
very thin
transistors the width of these fins is
only six nanometers okay so six
nanometers is
25 to 30 atoms across and they repeat
this over the entire wafer
just about perfectly it's just a huge
feat in engineering
but these types of devices are exactly
the kind of devices that your phones and
computers either have or will have in
the near future and it's a way that
nanotechnology
is directly impacting you right now how
do you make stuff that small like
obviously
it's not handmade so is it like
factories and stuff exactly so these are
made
using a technique called lithography you
basically cope the silicon wafer with a
polymer then you put a mask on it and
then you shine light through it
and the features of the mask the size of
those holes
determine the feature size in the chip
it's not just the size of the mask that
matters
it's the wavelength of the light that's
used we talked about nanotechnology
being science fiction before but this is
real stuff that's being produced that's
being made that's being
used every day by people in middle
school i've built all the like
the little switches where you turn the
electricity on and it goes from like one
thing to the other
but those are like the really big like
comical
like plugging in like legos and stuff
when we saw the picture of all of the
little ones like it's like a city it's
crazy how
simple and complex it is at the same
time exactly i couldn't put it
any better that's right
[Music]
so what's your major chemical
engineering what made you choose that
like any
freshman going into chemical engineering
i was like i like chemistry
so i'm gonna go into chemical
engineering but luckily i also like you
know
all the math and all the science too so
have you taken a quantum mechanics
course
i have i took that last year i think to
really get deep into nanomaterials and
nanoscale devices you really have to
understand to some level quantum
mechanics what it teaches us
as we make these devices smaller and
smaller their properties begin to now
depend
on the size and the orientation of these
devices
there are materials and you're taking a
2d materials class you know about this
that are intrinsically thin
like as they're grown as they're
fabricated they're already at the
nanoscale and they possess
these quantum confinement properties
that as a nanotechnologist you try to
exploit and so
the first ones i wanted to talk to you
about are quantum dots have you heard of
quantum dots before
yes so these are typically
semiconductors they can be
cadmium selenide cadmium sulfide zinc
cell not and they're small
clusters of atoms they can be from two
to 10 nanometers
what's interesting about these materials
well the other day we were talking about
the kind of different dimensions you can
have of nano technology so all the way
from like
0d to 3d if i remember correctly my
professor labeled it as 0d
that's correct yeah because of quantum
confinement once you get below
this 15 nanometer range the band gap of
the material
depends completely on the size of the
material so in bulk materials if you
want to change the band gap you have to
change the material right
but in these quantum dots specifically
just by changing the size you can change
their band gap
and because their band gap is changing
their optical properties are different
and you can precisely
tune the wavelength of light that they
emit just by changing their size
what are the applications of these
quantum dots there are people that are
exploring using these materials for
diode lasers there are companies that
are building displays from these
materials
and there are even people thinking about
if i take these quantum dots and i
change the chemistry on the outside so
they stick
to specific types of cells or tissue
that i could really do some interesting
imaging and therapeutic work to track
disease
even maybe to treat disease if you can
very precisely control the chemistry
how far away is this from being actually
used on an
industrial level the optical
applications are in development the
science has really been worked out
the health stuff because of all of the
things you have to consider when you're
putting something in someone's body
is definitely further out there for
example some of them are made from
cadmium cadmium's toxic you would never
put that in someone's body
but there are other materials like gold
and silver and titanium dioxide which
are
less toxic and people are exploring
using those so have you learned about
graphene
yeah do you know what this is carbon
nanotube carbon nanotube right so if you
roll up graphene
depending on how you roll it and the
angle you roll it with it has
different properties so if i roll it one
way it'll act like a metal
if i roll it a different way it'll act
like a semiconductor
the one that gets everyone most excited
is that the
electrons and holes move very fast
through through graphene and so there's
a lot of interest in using these for
certain types of high speed electronics
the other interesting application is
because it's one atom thin
it's very sensitive to changes in the
environment and so there's a lot of
interest in using them as diagnostics
it's on us researchers to find ways to
a control that process and then be to
actually build
some sort of interesting technology from
them so you've been talking about
the different ways you can say roll
these nanotubes so how do you go about
building and controlling these nanotubes
in terms of their diameter
so you're you're speaking my language
this is what i spent many years of my
life
working on you don't physically roll up
graphene you
grow nanotubes by basically taking
nanocrystals
and you deposit them on a surface and
then you do a cvd process chemical vapor
deposition so you basically
flow in a carbon source the carbon
dissolves in a nanocrystal
and then once the nanocrystal is
saturated the nanotubes
precipitate out of them in tubes then
you have to develop ways to go
into this pile of nanotubes and pull out
exactly the ones that you want
so i have to find ways to program them
to go
exactly in the places that i want i
modify the surface of the nanotube
with specific molecules that recognize
one type of surface over another and
then i just pattern the surface
and the tubes just land exactly where we
want them to and it's still very much in
the research stage the ultimate goal
is to build functional high speed
electronics using these these new
materials
in my nano materials class actually just
a couple days ago we were talking about
different applications of nanotechnology
and things we know
and we touched on the topic that right
now silicon is
kind of down to the smallest level that
it can get and so we have scientists out
there researching
other materials drilled by silicon yeah
100 that's right and that's the
motivation for looking at these
emerging materials but i would never bet
against the
innovation and the creativity in this
nano electronics space
tens of thousands of scientists every
time they hit
a barrier at least historically as a guy
they have found a way to overcome it i
mean it's a real
marvel in ingenuity so i gotta ask the
lights that are behind you
is that related to the quantum dots that
you work with at all it's just pretty
lights
but now that you suggested it these were
inspired
by the array of quantum dots that we
showed earlier so that's the story i'm
going to stick with
i like it well thank you so much this
was all so very interesting
so you're a graduate student and so tell
me a bit about your work i'm working on
energy storage materials and
the most popular uh our batteries that
we work on a lot of the revolution
that's come
in electronics is kind of our model to
try and use some nanoscale advances and
put them in
uh to batteries what is it about
nanomaterials
that scale and the properties of these
materials that make them
uniquely promising to incorporate into
battery technology
so for batteries one of the main
constraints when we're designing
batteries
is trying to maintain or reduce the
volume and mass
of the components and nanomaterials are
particularly
well suited to adding functionality
while having this negligible increase in
volume
so we get a huge benefit from using
nanomaterials without sacrificing
the volume of the battery what is it
exactly that you're trying to tease out
of these materials to improve
the battery's performance at first one
of the main things that we did was use
nanomaterials to add conductivity and so
carbon analysis and graphene are really
good at adding conductivity to
batteries and then in the subsequent
years nanomaterials have been really
interesting
from things like incorporating sensors
into batteries so increasing the
functionality of batteries
having some responsive materials that
use
things like graphene sheets that are
incorporated into a matrix and then you
add a safety functionality to a battery
we're trying to squeeze out almost all
the functionality that we can and as new
nanomaterials are being discovered in
their new properties being discovered
a lot of the time that that someone
tries to think of a way to translate
that into a battery
because the materials are so small
they're at the nano scale
their properties are dominated by
quantum mechanics which means that
even slight changes in their size in
their orientation
get profound changes in their properties
and while that's
very scientifically interesting and it
allows you to tune their properties by
making
subtle changes from a technology point
of view it actually is it's a bit of a
headache
in the sense and technology we want to
optimize for a property
and then repeat that over and over again
so what are some of the challenges
that you face in the lab related to
working with these materials and trying
to incorporate them into
uh into the batteries i think every step
of a process in a battery is kind of
something where you have to think about
how would this translate to making a
battery in terms of
the production one thing that i think is
very interesting about the field of
nanoscale materials in general is that
how you make the material changes
the properties a lot and so if we claim
that this 2d material has this property
then tying that to the battery
performance is something that's pretty
difficult to do it takes a few steps in
between so we have to think kind of
creatively with
how we can do that that's actually i
think a very common problem
we can build a device in the lab it
could be a transistor can be a battery
and then you ask the question okay so
what's the next step how do we take it
from that lab demonstration
into a technology the kind of work that
i'm very interested in
is developing tools to make
the exact type of materials that you
want the tools that we use in the past
for conventional
fabrication just don't work with these
these materials because
they're all grown from the bottom up
they're intrinsically small
and you have to find ways to either use
chemistry or some other means to
get them to assemble into the structures
that you want
to actually either grow specifically
what you want or after you grow them to
pull out the ones that you want you need
to be able to
build that same thing over and over
again with the exact same properties
no one institution no one research lab
no one
national lab is going to solve all of
these problems on their own because they
are difficult problems
and there is a real important payoff at
the end and it's going to take all of us
making our contributions to push to push
these this field forward
[Music]
i remember reading your papers when i
was a student and you know we're all
trying to
create these materials and finding ways
to exploit their
their properties what i love and i'm
delighted that you're here to talk to us
about is how you took inspiration from
nature and sort of recognize that
nature's figure out a way
to both synthesize incredibly complex
nanostructures with high functionality
and how you sort of were inspired by
that to do the research that you're that
you're doing now life gave us this
toolkit that
is already on the nanoscale so we think
that that's a great place to think about
making materials on the nanoscale and
manipulating materials on the nanoscale
and actually and wiring them together as
well
this abalone shell you can see the
exquisite beautiful
colors and structures of it this is a
nano composite material
if you take this and fracture it and you
look at it in a scanning electron
microscope what you'll see is it's made
out of these beautiful tablets
and i studied that as a graduate student
i looked at that and i said that is
completely
amazing you have an organism in the
ocean that takes what's in its
environment which is
calcium and carbonate that's dissolved
in the water and templates it into this
really exquisite structure and so you
think that's great calcium carbonate is
great but what if we wanted to make a
solar cell or
a another electronic device or a
a battery how would you get an organism
to do that and you say okay that's a
really crazy idea
but is it really that crazy if this
abalone
you know already figured out how to do
it you know 500 million years ago so
we're saying okay
abalones build shells can viruses build
solar cells can viruses build
catalysts can they build uh batteries
using the same
kind of idea it's really fascinating
work especially now we're all familiar
with with viruses and how they act and
i'm not aware of any viruses that build
nanostructures so i mean how did you
come to that and then how do you
actually
you know program a virus to do your
bidding we work on something called
bacteriophages
it's a virus with dna this particular
bacteriophage called
m13 bacteriophage is made up of single
stranded dna
and proteins it's long and thin so it's
880 nanometers in length
and it's about nine nanometers in
diameter
and so one of the reasons i love it is
it spans the nanoscale and almost the
micron scale at the same time
take the single strand dna obviously a
model and you can
cut it with molecular scissors and you
can put a new piece of dna in between
and so you put a small piece of dna in
there that doesn't doesn't belong there
and that piece of dna is going to
randomly code for a protein now the next
time that
that virus is replicated within a
bacterial host
it'll be able to put a new protein
sequence on the coat just a short
protein sequence on the coat
maybe like eight or twelve amino acids
in length and just like that avalon is
going to grab
calcium and build calcium carbonate
we're gonna have our viruses
build iron phosphate for a battery
electrode material
or gallium arsenide or cad sulfide for a
semiconductor material
so you've evolved and i suppose trained
these viruses to build the materials
that you want them to build by exposing
them to the raw materials and then
you know evolving their their function
we're trying to build electronics from
nanomaterials the critical issue that
we're facing is how do you go from those
single experiments with the single
material
understanding its properties how do you
scale that to the billions of devices
that you need in a technology
it is a you know a chemistry driven
approach we're not going to grow them
exactly where we want them but to take
that one
you know one step and to tie it into
what you're doing it sounds like there
could be an area of collaboration where
instead of using sort of conventional
chemistry that we can train some of
these biological elements to do that to
do that work
work for us biology is is chemistry
molecules proteins and dna work with all
the same kinds of bonding and
and things that the chemicals that that
you're going to be looking for in these
in these processes
it's put together uh in a way that
when a a protein or enzyme uh folds it
almost always folds
correctly that's kind of the beauty of
it the predictable aspect of it
encoded in its dna if we need to make it
the same
over and over again then as long as you
have the right dna sequence
dna is a beautiful structure on the
nanoscale and there's really
really cool incredible work on dna
origami where dna can fold into just the
right
right structure and so i can see that as
an interface
that would be really um cool and
interesting in your work and you can
have the virus make the dna for the dna
origami and then use dna to
assemble your uh beautiful structures
it's really fascinating you have all
these little worker viruses building the
materials for you how are you
then applying these materials that
you're that you're building we started
thinking about
how can we make an impact in cancer we
do it mostly
in imaging technology to look deep
inside the body non-invasively with
light
and the way that we came about that was
through solar cells and batteries
we trained our viruses to pick up carbon
nanotubes and hold on to them very very
tightly
and then we'll we'll give a virus a
second gene to code for a protein
to grow in the case of a battery a
battery electrode material
it allows it to weave together a good
electrical conductor
and a good ionic conductor at the same
time all in the
within this really really small space
and the optical properties of these
carbon nanotubes are in the wavelength
that is interesting for imaging deep
inside the body
we started building a bunch of imaging
tools that could image
um above a thousand nanometers uh
wavelength and so this is in
near ir's and that's a really special
window where you have some optical
transparency
of of tissue in the body the other gene
we engineered to find ovarian cancer we
developed
imaging tools with harvard medical
school and mit lincoln labs
to find tiny ovarian tumors it's hard to
see things less than a centimeter in
size
with ovarian cancer just based on the
location in the body
but with our imaging system we could
find tumors that were below a millimeter
in size actually
looking ahead five years ten years you
know where do you see
your own work and maybe the field more
broadly the future i'd like to see is
environmentally friendly chemistry
and materials synthesis and i think that
we're really going that way if we think
about
batteries of the future solar cells of
the future uh thinking about
earth abundant materials and processes
that are compatible with the earth
and environment one of the things i love
about about ammo science is it tends to
break up the silos between those
traditional
scientific disciplines my training was
in chemistry but i had a very quickly
merged chemistry in physics and now i
see an area where chemistry
physics and biology are coming together
to produce new materials and new
technology into it and to advance the
field forward and so being in this field
you kind of have to cross-pollinate you
know between these different disciplines
and kind of advance the field together
i agree completely we like to solve
problems nanobio
is the toolkit that we bring a lot it
happens to be a very
strong and evolving toolkit that's
another thing that i love about
biology is if you can come up with a
solution
that's not perfect at all to begin with
when you're making a battery electric
material or
any kind of material you're making you
have evolution
on your side to try to make it better
and better
as a function of time that can be quite
rapid so angela thank you so much for
joining us
and i look forward to seeing more work
coming out of your lab in the in the
future
thanks for having me george it was
really fun to interact and i'm very
excited about our future collaboration
me too
absolutely
i really enjoy talking to these five
different people about nanotechnology
nanotechnology is a field that affects
all of us
every day as it finds its way into a
variety of applications
and i hope you enjoyed it as well and
see the impact that nanotechnology has
on your life today
and how much more of an impact it will
have on all of our lives in the future